hello and welcome to bloodline the
taxonomy of fear where we break down
what if anything makes a movie scary i
am jordan crociola and i'm jay david and
uh today we're going to take a look at
mark tonderai's house at the end of the
street house at the end of the street
stars not one but two oscar nominees
jennifer lawrence for her role in
winter's bone not her role in hunger
games yes and elizabeth shu for her role
as a prostitute in leaving las vegas
greedy prostitutes and uh gilbertos who
was from tv's alley mcbeal you know
probably 12 and i was on the air what do
you think about that yeah and alongside
them max terriott of the upcoming show
bates motel on annie and also gap model
as a youngin i think i prefer the gap
model credit
what defines psychological horror does
house at the end of the street fit that
bill
first criteria i'm going to say
empathy-based fear in a psychological
horror movie we want to care about the
lead character so we care about what
happens to them
mom this is beautiful as good as
jennifer lawrence is and she's great she
actually pulls off a great performance
considering the kind of you know
middling nature of the movie but i
really i cared about what happened to
her movie not so good i'm gonna say it
didn't quite satisfy the empathy-based
the empathy-based criteria we follow her
around we're not but we don't super she
had a little bit of a personality
disorder she would just like blurt out
everything she said and she was super
nosy which is really off-putting yeah i
couldn't really buy that she was a
totally innocent thing number two
justifiable motivation of the antagonist
it has to be something not too
outlandish that actually is kind of
relatable like if it happened to us
maybe
maybe i could become a homicidal maniac
if that happened to me yeah no not here
to judge i felt like the villain's
motivation in this movie was really weak
it kept they kept sort of unfolding and
pulling these layers back as to what the
motivation was but eventually it just
turned out to be
creative indecision and the end was
totally predictable why is ryan jacobson
still living there what exactly happened
there his parents were murdered and his
sister disappeared
do you hear something
speaking of scary this psychological
horror category
a tension-based kind of fear the the
scares lie in that anxiety that builds
up to that kind of final fight or chase
whatever the crescendo is but the meat
of the movie the payoff is kind of
secondary to that anxiety you feel the
whole time for that protagonist you're
supposed to be empathizing with and in
the case of this movie
uh it was a little too stilted and a
little too much of a patchwork for me to
really get into that build up which
relates to number four at least gory it
was there was not a drop of blood in
this entire movie
it was weird people were getting stabbed
no blood there was maybe the glorious
thing was maybe like a second degree
burn yeah clean to the point of
unbelievable like if i got smacked in
the face like like happens in this movie
i would have you know a lip balm she was
a little too pretty throughout the whole
movie stunning really yeah and number
five uh for psychological horror the the
protagonist or the victim has to emerge
victorious and free from whatever kind
of physical or emotional psychological
entrapment that they are suffering and
that happens in this movie yeah they end
up they end up uh they take vengeance
and and they end up free uh kind of the
mother-daughter relationship they find a
bond there which works there's nothing
nothing bonds mother and daughter like
uh facing a serial killer yeah no we
bond under the most extreme
circumstances so it was it was kind of
successful and it sort of fit the bill
but ultimately not all that scary it had
the tropes but it didn't set itself
apart enough in the very
homogeneous horror genre yeah to kind of
to kind of give you the the creeps and
the crawlies throughout the movie it
just sort of fell a little bit the
tropes but not the actual successful
combination
yeah
i just had them all
if there's anything redeeming about the
least redeeming genre of movies is the
survival lessons that you perhaps can
learn number one number one if the house
is affordable there's a reason for it
serial killer pedophile black mold leaky
pipe don't move in
number two trust the town skeptic they
might seem crazy
they've been there a while they know
some stuff yes number three your mom may
have been a drunk sled in high school
but listen to her she's been around the
block a few times in one way more or
another so just listen to her advice
take it number four you are not your
child's friend you are their parent set
some rules enforce them i do not want
the two of you to be alone in his house
and number five to quote the very wise
kelly clarkson what doesn't kill you
makes you stronger kelly doing her
homework there quoting some friedrich
nietzsche who came before her on that
one i'm going to go with kelly clarkson
okay
jay any uh 30 minutes mostly because i
was really pissed that the the preview
was so deceptive what they promised was
a different movie
and i'm gonna say maybe maximum 45
minutes because if i were a 16 year old
girl trapped in a house that's generally
terrifying but nothing really
specifically related to the movie yeah
yeah
my pick is pascal legeres martyrs
actually no i'm not going to recommend
that movie because the second half of
the movie is so brutal and so horrible
so let's go with jordan's pick i'm gonna
go spiral a cool little independent
creepy movie from 2007 eerie similar
kind of protagonist dealing with a
similar kind of creepy antagonist guy
just to really check it out art house
film yuri gets into your skin kind of
thing
so that's it for this episode of
bloodline we'll be back in a couple
weeks with hopefully a scarier movie
uh email us with any questions comments
concerns at bloodline wired.com we'd
love to hear from you and as we like to
say here bloodline remember it's just a
movie